well we have learned a lot more about
what hunter biden's been up to
new messages between hunter biden and
his chinese-american
assistant have just been published in
the daily mail which all of a sudden is
an essential news outlet have you
noticed
our own matt finn has digested this
story and has it for us tonight hey matt
hi tucker the daily mail reports there
were some unusual messages recovered
from hunter biden's laptop that was
supposedly abandoned at that delaware
repair shop biden's chinese american
secretary joshie bao
offered biden anti-trump talking points
as
biden's father was preparing to run for
the white house and apparently had in
her possession
biden's dog tag chain necklace that he
was pictured wearing
in at least one shirtless photo the
secretary was assigned to biden
in a joint venture he and his uncle
established with chinese oil giant cefc
that venture went belly up in 2018
when businessman patrick hoe who hunter
biden reportedly referred to as the
spy chief of china was indicted by u.s
officials
in an email from 2018 the secretary
suggests hunter biden take
as much money from that failed venture
writing in part quote
i'm a bit hesitated to say this to you
because i don't want you to
misunderstood me as a messed up
bad girl here is my two cents whatever
money from hudson west
please take them as much as possible the
secretary also messaged in 2019
quote if there's anyone who deserves to
be scrutinized for doing business with
chinese it would be
donald trump what's not clear from the
daily mail's report is
whether biden responded to any of these
emails in fact the secretary
tucker complained that he did not tucker
amazing story matt finn thanks so much
in that story in the daily mail there's
also
the claim that that chinese woman sent
oppo to hunter biden for the campaign
the journalist who broke the story joins
us monday with more details